herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
die gute nachricht sie reden es gibt
verhandlungen in der türkei zwischen der
ukraine und russland und soeben ist der
ukrainische aussenminister vor die
presse getreten wir hören was er zu
sagen hat
um eine lösung nach lösungen zu suchen
für die humanitären probleme im land ich
bin bereit mich erneut zu treffen mit
minister labor in diesem format wenn es
aussichten gibt auf substanzielle
diskussion
und auch die ernsthafte suche nach
lösungen ich glaube wenn zwei
außenminister sich treffen dann
haben sie per definitionem das mandat
über frieden sicherheit und andere frank
zu verhandeln dass man da das ist ihm ja
von ihren parlamenten anvertraut worden
und von ihrer politischen führung und
ich bin bereit
auf diesem wege weiter zu verhandeln mit
dem ziel den krieg in der ukraine zu
beenden
das leid der ukrainischen zivilisten zu
beenden und
unser
gebiet von den russischen
besatzungstruppen zu befreien ich werde
nun ein paar worte auf ukrainisch
vortragen
wir hatten
kollegen der türkischer kollege
hat
eine gute arbeit geleistet und hohe
professionalität in seinen
dieses gespräch
ich bin zu diesen gesprächen gekommen
mit zwei aufkommen das wäre das erste
wäre die einrichtung von humanitären
korridor für
die belagerten zivilisten in europa
weil
die humanitäre lage in dieser stadt ist
prekär und
meine zweite aufgabe wäre die
vereinbarung von dem 24-stündigen
waffenstillstandes
in puncto 1
hoffe ich dass minister lawrow sie hat
darüber mit den verantwortlichen
personen in russland sprechen und wir
das doch auch die wege bringen können
ich hoffe dass die russische föderation
aus aber einen menschlichen
überlegungen aus mitleid zu den
zivilisten die unter russischen
überschüssen leiden darunter auch die
babys
tausende von denen jetzt auch der
schwelle des todes schweben
dass die russen eben aus diesen
überlegungen
die einrichtung des humanitären
korridors aus mario pohl
einrichten wir dasselbe gilt auch für
die stadt summe
[Musik]
wir können leider den krieg wir werden
den krieg nicht aufhalten können
da der ukrainische aussenminister im
prinzip das was auf englisch schon
gesagt haben du noch ein signal aber wir
werden jetzt verlangt
gegen diese
klage der türkischen kollegin
aufgegriffen denn wir sind für jegliche
kontakte zu den problemen die es
heutzutage dem ukrainischen der
ukrainischen krise zugrunde liegen es
betrifft auch die wege aus der krise so
das einzige was wir gleich
gekennzeichnet haben diese kunst sagte
müssen einen mehrwert bringen und wir
gehen davon aus dass diese kontakte
nicht dafür benutzt werden von unseren
ukrainischen kollegen die solche sachen
regelmäßig machen diese kontakte werden
nicht dafür genutzt um zu der viren die
realen wirklichen verhandlungen die auf
dem belorussischen boden stattfinden und
sich entwickeln auf dem ebene von zwei
delegationen die von den präsidenten von
belarus und russlands in ihrem amt
bestätigt worden sind und das heutige
gespräch hat erneut bestätigt dass
dieser track dieser weg alternativlos
bleibt der in weißrussland wir haben
heute uns vor allem über die initiative
der türkischen freunde ausgetauscht
humanitären fragen wir haben auch
erklärt welche massnahmen von unseren
boden drogen aufgegriffen werden um
den zivilisten in der ukraine zur
unterstützung der menschen die
geworden sind die von den sogenannten
freiwilligen bataillons ausgenutzt
werden und auch die anderen
verteidigungskräfte die werden als
lebendiger schuldtiteln aber all diese
fakten all diese tatsachen die werden
mehrfach pro tag unter anderem auch von
unseren auswärtigen amt und dem
verteidigungsministerium mitgeteilt
wir haben bestätigt dass die initiative
die ihrerseits
von russland geäußert wurde zur öffnung
von humanitären korridors diese
initiative bleibt in kraft
die routen von solchen korridors die
zeit der eröffnung werden bestimmt von
denjenigen die die situation am boden
kontrollieren und im griff haben die
analysieren die situation umgehen von
der notwendigkeit der meistens
effizienten roben für die zivilisten zu
finden
und natürlich
haben wir unsere ukrainischen kollegen
daran erinnert dass bei der letzten
runde der verhandlungen in belarus die
russische seite ganz konkrete schon
projektbezogene dokumente vorgestellt
und überlegungen und die ukrainische
seite hat diese vorschläge übernommen
nach kiew gebracht und hat uns
versichert dass wir in der nächsten zeit
eine konkrete antwort darauf bekommen
werden denn sie haben möchten ein
gespräch in belarus führen zwar
ernsthaft die formal nicht dass wir uns
gegenseitig mit
unverbindlichen papieren loswerden
sondern dass wir die vorschläge
bestätigen im allgemeinen kontext der
lösung der ukrainischen krise verwendet
werden müssen im kontext der
gewährleistung der sicherheit auf den
europäischen kontinent
dabei müssen natürlich alle seiten aller
länder berücksichtigt werden mit ihren
interessen so dass in kürze worüber wird
heute gesprochen haben jetzt bin ich
bereit ihre fragen zu beantworten
ob wir da jemanden haben von den
kollegen vom russischen fernsehen
auf die erste frage
haben sie die kosten die für die
russische föderation entstehen
ausgerechnet
die
kosten
errechnet uns haben sie mehr kosten oder
weniger
das war die erste frage
haben sie haben sie vor auch außerhalb
der ukrainischen grenzen eine operation
durchzuführen
und haben sie auch eine option offen
wegen militärischer
zurückschlagen in der übersetzung aber
wenn ich die frage beantwortet dazu
wie die sonderoperation sich entwickeln
so werden diese einschätzungen vor allem
von den vertretern vom
verteidigungsministerium gegeben und
natürlich der präsident hat mehrfach
unterstrichen dass die operation nach
plan abläuft was die waffenlieferungen
die ukraine anbelangt aus dem ausland
jahr
wir sehen wie
das ja wie gefährlich es ist was unsere
westlichen kollegen machen inklusive die
europäische union krieg gegen alle
grundwerte und alle so genannten
grundsätze
waffenlieferungen für tödliche waffen
unterstützt einschließlich tausende von
komplexen die man einfach von der
schulter bewegt bewegen kann an jeden
ort und die auch sehr oft von
terroristen benutzt worden sind um eine
gefährdung
der flugzeuge der zivilluftfahrt so
machen wohin land in diese waffen später
das ist die frage die wir unseren
kollegen von stellen in der union in der
europäischen union wenn die interesse
daran wie man
ende der politik machen könnte die
kleine ausgefahren wurde nämlich eine
gefährdung der russischen föderation
bis jetzt haben wir noch keine antwort
darauf wie dieser waffen dem es
kontrollieren das heißt wir haben eine
gefährdung eine gefahr für viele weitere
leite für zivilluftfahrt und das nicht
nur in der ukraine im ukrainischen
himmel sondern auch europaweit groß dass
ihre frage angelangt und wir planen
weitere länder zu überfallen nein das
planen wir nicht wir haben auch keine
nicht überfallen
haben wir mehrfach erklärt wir haben
eine situation die unmittelbare
gefährdung für die sicherheit der
russischen föderation
unseren mehrjährigen aufrufen und
vorschlägen hat uns keiner gehört
präsident putin hat mehrfach sich zu
diesem thema geäußert und die neuen
tatsachen die wir jetzt erfahren auch
den befreiten gebieten der ukraine unter
anderem internets und so hans gewinnt
bestätigt dass der überfall auf die
sinnvollsten republiken schon längst
sorgfältig geplant war und zwar schon in
diesem monat im laufenden monat und
natürlich die zu ist absolut widerlich
und
enttäuschend das pentagon
betreibt
angesicht der biologie waffen laboren
auf dem ukrainischen boden
experimentiert mit pathogenen stoffen
die später für biologische waffen
benutzt werden können und dass die
vertreter von washington publik dass
widerlegt haben sollen diese gerüchte
wie sie sagen dass sie irgendwelche
verbote tätigkeit in der ukraine zu
betreiben darüber braucht man sich nicht
zu wundern dass die europäische union
mit einer stimme sagt auch die hätten
keine informationen über die tätigkeit
der amerikaner in diesem gebiet der
biologischen waffen das wundert uns
nicht und was die vertreter der uno
gesagt haben sie hätten auch keine
informationen diesbezüglich auch das
wundert uns nichts denn natürlich haben
die amerikaner haben diese tätigkeit
insgeheim betrieben genauso wie sie in
anderen staaten des postsowjetischen
raumes arbeiten indem sie die laboren
rund um die russische föderation gründen
auch in der chinesischen republik in der
chinesischen volksrepublik das sind
tatsachen
ist nicht zu widerlegen es gibt eine
internationale konvention zum verbot von
biologischen waffen und deswegen müssen
jeder jeden alle staaten bericht
erstatten der weltöffentlichkeit über
tätigkeit in dieser richtung wenn ich
ihre frage richtig verstanden habe so
ist meine antwort aber diejenigen die
waffen in die ukraine pumpen müssen uns
schon verstehen dass sie verantwortung
für ihre handlungen tragen genauso wie
diejenigen
weitere soldaten söldner in die ukraine
schicken oder
sie unterstützen damit die
rechtsradikalen in der ukraine
eine frage von
eine frage von 10 bis
ins
land
hat verschiedene worte benutzt um die
invasion in der ukraine zu rechtfertigen
sich seinerzeit für das ukrainische volk
aber die können sie die bombardierung
eines entbindung heinz und eine
verbindungs krankenhauses und eines
kinderkrankenhauses recht fertig
also kinder und schwangere frauen zu
bombardieren ist doch ein
kriegsverbrechen und russlands selbst
hat mit enormen zahlungsausfällen zu
rechnen also die russische wirtschaft
geht schlimmer in die knie ab hier zuvor
können sie den leuten gegenüber
rechtfertigen dass ihre wirtschaft
ruinieren für einen mit dem version an
die die rest der welt nicht glaubt
[Musik]
zum ersten mal haben wir mit
pathetischen ausrufen zu tun dass
bezüglich die sogenannten untaten von
russischen militärs
am 17 märz vor drei tagen
am 17 am 6 ich kann es jetzt nicht genau
sagen bei der sitzung vom uno
sicherheitsrat
wurde nicht sagen von unserer delegation
vorgelegt dazu dass dieses krankenhaus
in bildungs krankenhaus schon längst vom
bataillon azoff und anderen radikalen
besetzt worden ist alle schwangeren
frauen alle
krankenschwester und ärzte sind da
vertrieben wurden und es wurde benutzt
von also von unserer radikalen militärs
von der bataillons oft diese tatsachen
haben wir bereits vor drei tagen
vorgelegt machen sie ihre
schlussfolgerungen selber wie im
manipuliert wie die öffentliche meinung
in der ganzen welt gerade manipuliert
wird ich habe heute auch eine reportage
auch bei ihnen dazu gesehen auch in
anderen westlichen massenmedien
es ist sehr emotional aber leider ist
die andere seite
in dieser situation sie also seid ihr
die erlaubt eine objektive meinung sich
zu bilden diese anderer seite die hat
nicht wirklich verachtet
darum werden wir uns schon selber
kümmern darum kümmert sich der präsident
zu unserer regierung
sind nur noch einmal davon überzeugt
worden sie sagen sie dir benutzen viele
worte um zu rechtfertigen was wir gerade
in der ukraine tu dir wissen sie
berücksichtigt wir haben
längst gesagt in der ukraine passiert
das was man mit russland schon seit
jahren
versucht wenn der westen seit anfang der
2000er jahren von den ukrainern verlangt
hat vor jedem wahlen sich festzulegen
sind ihn mit russland oder mit dem
westen das heißt entweder oder gehst du
mit uns oder bist du gegen uns was sind
das für westliche werte
die hinein geblasen werden in die köpfe
der ukrainischen menschen des
ukrainischen volkes wir beobachten auch
manipulationen in den der sogenannte
prowestlicher kandidat zusätzlich als
letzter landete wie es 2009 der fall war
als großen künstler duos gegen
die verfassung der verfassung der
ukraine und musste in der ukraine kostet
institutionelle entscheidung getroffen
werden eine dritte runde die wahlen zu
veranstalten diese manipulationen gab es
in allen jahren immer wieder keiner hat
in den jahren jemanden bedroht aber
immer wieder wurde ukraine zu einem pro-
westlichen experiment experiment ist
moment geschafft wo keiner wurde zu
einem instrumenten ausgebildet und als
nato dann auch verlangte dazu keine auch
dieses freiheit hätte sich nato
anzuschließen als in der ukraine schon
bestellungen geschaffen wurden als
unmittelbare bedrohung des virus
lackierten dach stationiert wurden und
jetzt wir wissen auch biologische waffen
da in den laboren entwickelt wurden auch
das wurde den ukrainischen menschen und
der welt öffentlichkeit verheimlicht es
kein richtiges und als der ukraine aus
auch auf den amazon freien staates
verzichten musste dann haben wir
aufgerufen aufgerufen zum gewissen und
zu vernunft unserer westlichen partner
denn es geht um sicherheit auf dem
europäischem boden in europa und hat uns
gesagt ihr könnt reden was ihr wollt
aber die frage der nato osterweiterung
ist unsere sache das lesen wir ohne euch
entscheiden und macht euch keine angst
eure sicherheit wird nicht bedroht aber
deswegen warum sollen die fragen unserer
sicherheit und interessen der russischen
föderation von natur entschieden werden
wenn die uns versichern wir werden nicht
vertraut man mit russland kann man soll
nicht reden deswegen
sind wir nicht daran interessiert unsere
handlungen in der ukraine zu
rechtfertigen wir haben diese handlungen
vorgestellt wir haben ganz konkrete
vorschläge gemacht werden wollen keine
militarisierung der ukraine ob mit oder
ohne nato man kann auch ohne nato der
amerikanische raketen
stationieren die russland im visier
haben
wir wollen nicht die tendenz aus
erhalten des aufbaus zu einem
nationalistischen staat mit
neonazistischen traditionen aber
demokratische boden mit marschieren den
ss truppen die
den präsidenten salutieren und einiges
mehr
wenn diese
terroristen trainiert werden um ihre
taten zu verüben und natürlich wollen
wir dass ukraine ein neutrales land
bleibt hinter präsident putin hat
mehrfach gesagt er
bestätigt wenn wir darauf bestehen dass
nach dass ich nicht erweitert wollen wir
nicht den ukrainern ihr recht auf
sicherheit absprechen wir sind bereit
die garantien für die ukrainische
sicherheit abzusprechen aber im kontext
der sicherheit der anderen europäischen
länder und russlands und das jetzt was
sie lernen gerade gesprochen hat dass
langsam die klarheit darüber
durchsickert das macht uns gedämpft
optimistisch was unsere wirtschaftlichen
problemen beladen die werden wir schon
im griff kriegen wir haben auch andere
schwierigkeiten bewältigt auf allen
etappen unserer geschichte als diese
schwierigkeiten entstanden sind aber
diesmal ich möchte sie versichern wir
kommen aus dieser krise
mit einer gestärkten psychologie und
einer klaren vorstellung
illusion frei darüber ob westen zu einem
sicheren partner werden kann wir haben
keine illusionen mehr darüber dass der
besten dann über die werte gesprochen
wird es wird daran nicht geglaubt und
wir sind ganz sicher der westen wird
jedes verraten in jedem moment sogar
sich selbst und eigene werte denn wo hat
man sonst stirbt das eigentumsrecht so
mit füßen getreten werden könnte die
gerade wie könnte man früher sehen dass
unschuldsvermutung ist als säule das
rechtssystem des westens dermaßen
ignoriert wird und grob verletzt
deswegen
ich versichere sie werden unsere
probleme im überwältigen können aber wir
tun alles damit wir nie wieder vom
westen in den gebieten abhängen die
entscheidend sind für uns erfolg
jetzt
russische fernsehen
konstantinos kind
möchte ein zitat aus keith bringen die
heute der stellvertreter der chef des
präsidialamtes hat gesagt er ist bereits
so diplomatisch lösen aber die
ernsthaften verhandlungen mit den russen
sind nur möglich auf den ebenen der
beiden präsidenten halten sie es für
sinnvoll jetzt oder in der nächsten zeit
ein treffen von den beiden präsidenten
zu organisieren die antwort alle wissen
ganz genau auf präsident putin lehnt nie
kontakte ab wir wollen nur dass diese
kontakte
die sie es wären nicht der kontakte als
solchen segen sondern damit wir
bestimmte entscheidungen und abkommen
dabei festhalten können wir haben dieses
thema heute mit herrn kollegen
angesprochen herr kollege hat auch diese
themen erwähnt diese auch gerade ich
habe daran erinnert wir sind klima dafür
dass wir uns treffen aber nur dann wenn
wir ein mehrwert dabei erzeugen tun und
eine problemlösung herbeirufen können
die ukrainische führung
nachdem eine konstitutionelle
verfassungswidrigen umsturz von 2014
imitiert oder simuliert treffen
simuliert konkrete entscheidungen
mit neuen kontakten
mit fernsehkameras bei laufen dann kann
das ich erinnere noch einmal 1 7 minsker
abkommen die blockiert worden sind von
berg von dem kiewer regime der präsident
der lenski hat damals immer wieder
aufgetreten das treffen dass es endlich
zusammen kommen noch einmal als wir die
ukrainischen kollegen daran erinnert
haben dass 2019 entschuldigung 2009
unser stern weist ein treffen im
normandie format gab und alle fragen
gingen schief und keiner der
entscheidung wurde umgesetzt dann gab es
kam es nie dazu aufrufen lassen ist
schon wieder treffen und dann werden wir
die entscheidungen von paris erzielen
aber warum haben wir uns in paris
getroffen wenn wir noch einsame durch
hören müssen und damit die
entscheidungen umgesetzt werden das
heißt diese strategie
in den kern der probleme zu ersetzen
durch äußerte effekte die normandie
format muss es größer werden muss
kleiner werden müssen die briten die
polen die amerikaner aber auge die
türkei mit am tisch sitzen dann gab es
noch eine andere idee
dass die franzosen und die deutschen
sich auch daran beteiligen also es war
ein bruder von immer neuen ideen aber
all diese ideen sind einfach zu erklären
die ist die sie
wollen keine richtigen handlung könnte
für die umsetzung von eigenen
entscheidungen treffen sondern die
erzeugen nur effekt der präsident putin
hat nichts gegen ein treffen mit dem
präsidenten syriens kirchhof war dass
die notwendigkeit von einem solchen
treffen wirklich entstehen wird aber
dafür muss die vorbereitungsarbeit
durchgeführt werden und das läuft über
den belarussischen weg sind schon
mehrere treffen stattgefunden unsere
konkreten vorschläge liegen vor die
ukrainische seite hat uns konkrete
antworten versprochen auf die warten wir
gerade
wir haben auch vertreter
von den ukrainischen medien von den
öffentlichen fernsehen der ukraine
russland
als die nazi führung für die netten
finanzierung grundgesetz zu
vertreibungen und folter ob es im creme
war mit dem tatarischen
bevölkerungsschwund im süden amateur
fall sind mehrere frauen gekidnappt
worden auch die tataren leila ibragimow
war ein abgeordneter dh sie haben in
diesen acht jahren früher hatten sie wir
sind an einer neuen ebene angekommen sie
kidnappen jetzt trauen da ist es wichtig
dass unsere türkischen kollegen wissen
dass jetzt
krimtataren abläuft das ist meine
kindheit region da bin ich aufgewachsen
die antwort lautet sie sagen sie reden
von tatsachen aber ich würde dafür ein
anderes wort mit f finden nämlich fake
mit fake news ist internet und
massenmedien gerade überfüllt ich habe
von dieser geschichte dieser quasi
entführung nichts gehört eine
abgeordneten aber ich weiß
über die manieren
für die regie von tief berühmt ist ich
habe gestern gehört der abgeordnete
schewtschenko wäre verschwunden ist aber
vielleicht schon gefunden
der an den verhandlungen in kiew
beteiligt war ist umgebracht worden erst
aus der ära von
sicherheitsdiensten der ukraine
hingerichtet während als stadtvater dann
hieß es es kam zu einer
verbrecherischen auseinandersetzung das
heißt wenn man sich in individuelle
geschichten vertieft kann man viele
empören viel empörendes und enttäuschend
das zu tage fördern aber wenn wir eine
episode nehmen und diese will man diese
episode nimmt wie oft er dunkeln und
falsch ist und damit die öffentliche
meinung versucht es hoch zu ross zu
bringen um antirussische politik zu
betreiben unter anderem in der türkei da
haben wir wieder mit einem
sucht zu tun durch
effekte eine kraft der ein ernsthaftes
gespräch zu ersetzen familie man kann
viele namen und nachnamen aufzählen also
ausgetauscht ja ich habe nur gesagt ich
werde mich ärgern aber ich habe von
diesem fall nicht gehört dafür habe ich
in sapporo sie hier verschwunden ist
entschuldigung entschuldigung es ist
eine pressekonferenz
ist es wichtig dass auch andere kollegen
fragen stellen
ich glaube sie haben schon ihre bilder
sie werden schon in ihrer heimat im
fernsehen zeigen sie haben ihr ziel
bereits erreicht jetzt die italienischen
kollegen bitte die frage
italien gesprochen da ist kein just am
besten irgendwie hier ist doch die
italienischen kollegen
hier gibt es demokratie
jeder der das mikro an sich reißen kann
macht das
gibt hin stimmen die sagen es seien
biologische waffen bei dem angriff
eingesetzt worden was sagen sie dazu
wir sind sehr darüber besorgt über die
tatsachen
erfahren haben hintergrund einige
dutzende von biologischen laboren auf
dem boden der ukraine gegründet hat im
rahmen seines programms für die
entwicklung der biologischen waffen
weltweiten das ist ein verstoß gegen die
entsprechende konvention über den
verbund verbot der toxischen waffen wir
haben eine entsprechende anfrage
gerichtet und wir wollen eine erklärung
bekommen
dass sie diese waffen schon eingesetzt
haben dazu habe ich keine fakten keine
tatsachen aber dass es sich um keine
friedlichen experimente handelte sondern
um entwicklung von biologischen waffen
und zwar ethnisch orientierter
biologischer waffen daran habe ich kaum
zweifel
das ist die russische tageszeitung
die usa erklären ganz klar dass die
botschafter
müssen die regierungen der länder der
welt daran überzeugen sich an die anti
russischen sanktionen beteiligen müssen
diese isolation von russland von dem
westen spricht
die ist es
unsere botschafter in jeder situation
werden orientiert von uns wir werden
informieren sie über die tatsachen über
unsere position die sich auf die
jeweilige situation bezieht dass es eine
aufgabe des auswärtigen amtes und unsere
botschafter der russischen föderation
bringen diese information weiter an die
regierungen der länder wo sie russland
vertreten damit ein objektives bild
entsteht in der ganzen welt herum zu
laufen und einen souveränen als
unabhängiges land
zu zwingen
einen auftrag von dem großen bruder
auszuführen dass sie wird nicht zu
unseren traditionen wir sind gut
erzogene höfliche menschen wie sie
wissen und das was die amerikaner machen
und sie machen kein hehl daraus dass sie
von der türkei verlangen von indien von
ägypten
von südostasiatischen staat nun sogar
von china sie fordern dass sie
die sanktionen der amerikaner
gesetzeswidriger sanktionen mitmachen so
viel missachtung gegenüber bedeutenden
staaten und großen nationen so was habe
ich mir nicht vorstellen zu ein
arbeitstier für die amerikaner scheint
alles gut zu sein um ihre
taten zur apotheke zu treiben jetzt
nein das sind italienischen sky news und
dann gibt's
aus großbritannien sie haben vor einiger
zeit gesagt russland habe keine absicht
ich verdiene zu fallen heute haben sie
gesagt in russland habe die ukraine
nicht überfahren aber es russland hat
die ukraine überfallen sie haben auch
gesagt russland würde keine zivilisten
in mitleidenschaft ziehen aber 1000 und
arbeit tausende wurden verletzt und
getötet warum sollten die ukraine sie
überhaupt ernst nehmen sollten sie ein
wort glauben was sie sagen warum sollte
der rest der welt ihm glauben
bindungs kliniken anbelangt dazu habe
ich mich geäußert aber sie wollen es
nicht hören unter die westlichen medien
werden es nie zeigen dass wir vor drei
tagen im sicherheitsrat bereits erklärt
habe was mich ein bildungs klinikum
passiert war es was die erklärung
anbelangt wir was machen wird und wer
was nicht machen wird wir haben bis
zuletzt versucht und gewollt das problem
auf diplomatische wege zu lösen wir
haben unterschiedliche dokumente dazu
vorgelegt zu einem bilateralen abkommen
mit den usa usa nato zu allen schlüssel
ist die fragen der europäischen
sicherheit
indem wir die interessen von allen allen
partnern allen ländern europas
berücksichtigt haben einschließlich der
ukraine man hat uns gesagt nein die
ukraine gehört zu uns wir entscheiden
wie der ukraine deren schicksal wir
werden es so tun wie das wollen auch
viele andere vorschläge von uns wurden
abgelehnt um einschließlich
nichtzulassung von erschaffung von
physischen gefahren für die russische
föderation auf dem ukrainischen boden
der präsident putin hat ganz klar
erklärt warum er sich für die sonder
operation entschieden hat ich hoffe auch
wenn das man es ihnen nicht erlaubt dass
ihren hörern und zuschauern zu erzählen
vielleicht lesen sie sich selber ein und
versuchen unsere logik zu verstehen wir
haben es klar dazu geäußert wir brauchen
wir wollen eine digitalisierte ukraine
die freundschaftliche uns gegenüber
gestimmt ist ein ukraine wo es keine
gefahr es zur gründung von dem nächsten
nationalsozialistischen staat gibt einen
ukraine wo es kein verbot für sie
russischer sprache und russische kultur
russische auch der boxer kirche gibt
all das hat sich angestaut und
angesammelt all das bis schon der fall
und hat schon wurde schon in den
gesetzen der ukraine festgehalten als
unsere wünsche unserer
ansprachen in den letzten acht jahren
dass sie irgendwie mit den ukrainischen
biografischen regierung reden wurden
abgelehnt und wurden verschwiegen
die letzte geschichte mit der russischen
sprache als die
ukrainische gesetz zur staatlichen
sprache für absurd wurde wo nur die
ukrainische sprache verwendung werden
sollte und alle anderen sprachen
so oder so war auch beim unterricht in
den grundschulen und auch an den
hochschulen auf dem verlorenen posten
waren und das war
für uns ein problem sondern auch
rumänien bulgarien haben sich dagegen
geäußert damit haben die ukrainische
macht ganz einfach gehandelt sie haben
eine ausnahme gemacht für die sprachen
der europäischen union dass sie sehr
nett so ist nur die russischer sprache
rechtlos geblieben in der ukraine obwohl
in der verfassung der ukraine eigentlich
die rechte für die ukrainische sprache
garantiert sind und der besten hat sich
beruhigt hat nichts gesagt das war ein
erneuter beweis dafür dass der westen
nur eines von der ukraine möchte dass
sogar eine ständig gegen russland arbeit
gegen alles russischen verstehen sie
dass der westen
beim referendum in creme gemacht hat das
waren so was von doppelter standards als
also zum beispiel in kosova wurde kein
referendum durchgeführt aber nato hat
extra mit den bombardements die
situation erschaffen damit jugoslawien
zerfällt
entscheidung von einem kosovarischen
organ wurde einfach die unabhängigkeit
erklärt oder ganze wälzen oder fast der
ganze westen hat beifall gespendet und
hat das als zeichen der demokratie
bestätigt warum dürfen die russen
ingrimm nicht las dass die albaner in
jugoslawien dürfen die albaner hat man
damit unterstützt das ich in diese
richtung bewegen weil ziel unter anderem
sind ziel von einem land wie
großbritannien ist und bleibt
und auch europaweit keine zu großen
staaten zu lässt das wissen wir doch
ganz genau und wahrscheinlich wurde
dieser ziele in bezug auf die russische
föderation verfolgt aber ich wiederhole
noch einmal schwierig wir haben früh
genug verstanden es geht nicht um die
ukrainer ist es geht um eine aggression
gegen alles russische
interessen
kultursprache
sicherheit und anderes und anderes mehr
und jetzt natürlich die reaktion des
westens auf unsere handlungen
entschuldigt mir dieses wort reaktion
die eine hysterische reaktion ist ein
beweis dafür dass er es ist ein kampf
um das recht russland
macht auf der politischen charakter der
welt zu bleiben mit der unter einhaltung
russischer interessen city wie china
gehört haben sortieren wir dass das war
live davor haben wir den ukrainischen
außenminister gehört es war ein treffen
heute in antalya in der türkei man hatte
hoffnungen dass es so etwas wie einen
fortschritt vielleicht geben könnte es
war ein erstes diplomatisches treffen
auf dieser ebene dass die außenminister
miteinander sprechen aber ich glaube
wäre das jetzt hier gehört hat hat zum
eingelernt diplomatie verlangt nerven
und fortschritte gibt es wenn überhaupt
in minimalen schritten ich glaube man
kann sagen und das hat der ukrainische
aussenminister clever gesagt im prinzip
wurde kein fortschritt erzielt was das
thema waffenruhe anbetrifft und auch bei
den flucht korridoren ist man sich nicht
wirklich näher
das einzige und das ist ja nun wirklich
das minimalste was es überhaupt gab das
ist eine bereitschaft gibt sich erneut
zu treffen und wer gerade den russischen
außenminister gehört hat man auch mit
den vorwürfen in jede richtung der muss
sich klar machen und wird auch sehen und
verstehen und das sehe ich auch aus
euren kommentaren da werden noch viele
zeiten ins land gehen die man brauchen
wird um da so etwas wie eine annäherung
überhaupt zu kriegen wollen wir das mal
sortieren und holen axel sturm dazu
unseren moskau korrespondenten der aber
gerade nicht in moskau sein kann weil
das für westliche korrespondenten
momentan kein sicherer platz ist und
deswegen schaltwerk gestorben hier aus
mainz dazu axel du hast das verfolgt was
lawrow gesagt hat
da war kein bewegen da war kein kein
zugeständnis in irgendeiner form da
waren die alten vorwürfe die man vorher
gehabt hat wie gesagt die erwartungen
waren schon nicht hoch aber muss man
sagen alles in allem ist das heute ein
enttäuschender tag
hallo ralf ja ich glaube das muss man
sagen das war eine sehr ernüchternde
veranstaltung du hast es gesagt die
erwartungen waren nicht hoch im vorfeld
aber was wir eben erlebt haben ist der
alte russische außenminister der im
prinzip dieselbe rhetorik bemüht wie
schon seit monaten der also gegen den
westen hetze gegen die führung in kiew
der führung in kiew nach wie vor die
legitimität ab spricht der nach wie vor
davon spricht dass sie nur ins amt
gekommen ist durch einen illegitimen
putsch 2014 also all diese dinge die wir
seit monaten hören in diese
diplomatischen positionen diese
ideologisch aufgeladenen positionen auch
in denen russland wirklich seit langem
schon festhängt
fangen wir vielleicht mal mit einer
frage an die kette gold via youtube
gestellter besser behauptet russland
eigentlich dass die ukraine nazis sind
ja ich habe das immer noch nicht so ganz
verstanden gibt es dafür irgendwelche
haltbaren anhaltspunkte
also ich habe den eindruck dass russland
ein gesellschaftliches phänomen
vorschiebt das durchaus nicht von der
hand zu weisen ist das aber sicherlich
überbewertet wird im kontext dieses
krieges es gibt in der ukraine durchaus
eine organisation die nennt sich rechte
sektorweit sektor diese organisation
beruft sich auf kollaborateure im
zweiten weltkrieg die an der seite der
wehrmacht gekämpft haben und in deren
geiste sozusagen gibt es die heute noch
in der ukraine das sind etwa da gibt es
nur schätzungen drüber 40 bis 60 tausend
mann im ganzen großen land ukraine
diese menschen haben inzwischen auch
einen politischen flügel gegründet der
aber weitgehend 1 1 ohne einfluss ist
auf die tagesgeschäfte in der politik
aber ich habe den eindruck dass immer
wenn lavrov von entnazifizierung und von
neonazis oder wie er eben sagte neonazis
die den präsidenten in kiew salutieren
spricht dass diese diese gruppe benutzt
wird um zu rechtfertigen was gerade in
der ukraine passiert
schauen wir vielleicht mal auf das was
gestern passiert ist die welt ist
entsetzt dass es diesen angriff auf die
entbindungsstation gegeben hat auch dazu
hat sich laut geäußert danach wurde er
gefragt vielleicht schauen wir noch auf
ein paar bilder die wir jetzt
einschlafen können um uns das noch mal
vor augen zu führen na ja das sind die
bilder von dem treffen dass es vorher
gegeben hat da sehen wir den türkischen
außenminister der sich mit dem
ukrainischen außenminister im vorfeld
getroffen hat auch da gab es sozusagen
erstmal die hoffnung dass es sozusagen
auf das geheiß von der türkei auf den
vermittlungsversuch der türkei heute
ergebnisse geben könnte wir holen die
bilder gleich nach von von mario pohl
aber vielleicht gelingt uns das noch
sonst machen wir erstmal weiter la ford
hat putin zitiert und gesagt es laufe
nach plan er hat auch gesagt was die
westlichen sanktionen anbetrifft das
wird man irgendwie überstehen wir werden
das in den griff bekommen so hat er sich
geäußert aber vor allem sei es eine
lektion für moskau das der westen kein
sicherer partner ist jetzt ist es ja
immer wichtig sich in solchen
krisenzeiten in die perspektive des
anderen hinein zu denken kann man da
etwas herauslesen was sozusagen aus dem
eigenen blickwinkel ein weiterhilft wenn
man künftig mit moskau in irgendeiner
form verhandeln will oder muss man
konsterniert feststellen die drehen sich
wie sie es wollen
ich glaube letzteres wäre etwas zu
simpel was ich gelernt habe in meiner
zeit in russland ist das tatsächlich die
russische führung die welt völlig anders
per zitiert anders sieht als die welt im
westen als westliche gesellschaften und
westliche regierungen da gibt es ein
fundamental unterschiedliches bild der
welt der geostrategischen zusammenhänge
und auch darüber was eine gesellschaft
gut tut und was ihr nicht gut tut aber
in solchen situationen wie im moment
wird eben ganz bewusst auch der westen
als feindbild auserkoren wir wissen dass
aus vielen anderen konflikten zuvor man
braucht immer ein feindbild an dem man
sich abarbeiten kann um herauszuarbeiten
vor der eigenen bevölkerung dass das
wofür man selbst steht was man selbst
vertritt der richtige weg ist der wahre
weg und der weg für den es sich lohnt zu
kämpfen ich habe den eindruck das ist
genau das was momentan in russland
passiert
darauf hat auch von biowaffen gesprochen
danach wurde er auch gefragt auf
ukrainischem boden er sagt das macht das
pentagon das sei widerlich und nicht
überraschend und auch no mercy fragt wie
youtube er wüsste gerne was die experten
davon halten dass die usa biologische
waffen dort ausprobieren sollen aber
gleichzeitig das land mit raketen
bedrohen und eben auch beschießen sind
sie noch ernst zu nehmen fragte aber
dazu noch meine frage sozusagen on top
was bedeutet das ist das ein
ablenkungsmanöver sind das nebelkerzen
in diesen kriegszeiten oder was hat es
damit auf sich
da muss ich ganz mit offenen karten
spielen mir ist nicht bekannt dass die
usa in der ukraine
anlagen fabriken herstellungs- städten
betreiben zur produktion von wie auch
immer gearteten kampfstoffen ich bin
aber auch kein geheimdienstler ich bin
politischer journalist insofern werden
wir da einfach abwarten müssen ich habe
das auch gelesen und auch vernommen und
glaubhaft zugehört es ist oft so dass
die russische führung nebelkerzen wirft
um vom eigentlichen ambitionen
abzulenken das ist sogar teil der
russischen militär ausbildung eine
eigene sonder division
ablenkungsmanöver irritationen streuen
und nachrichten zu streuen die einfach
nichts mit der realität zu tun haben
damit die aufmerksamkeit gebündelt wird
auf dinge die ablenken sollen von dem
eigentlichen vorgehen aber zu diesem
thema kampfstoffe kann ich leider nicht
sagen
abschließend noch drauf sagte jetzt
passiert mit der ukraine was mit
russland seit jahren passiert er hat
schwere vorwürfe dem westen noch mal
gemacht aber er wurde eben auch danach
gefragt ob es vielleicht ein treffen auf
präsidenten ebene geben könnte sprich
selensky und putin er hat nicht nein
dazu gesagt aber bedingungen genannt
dass es sinn mache nur bei wenn es einen
mehrwert gebe und alles was danach kam
klang für mich nicht so als würde er
diesen mehrwert in irgendeiner form
sehen schauen wir nach vorne und einfach
mal da deine einschätzung dessen was
dort moskau sozusagen mitgebracht hast
hat moskau überhaupt irgendein interesse
daran da eine lösung zu finden
da würde ich mich tatsächlich aus dem
fenster lehnen und sagen moskau hat kein
interesse zumindest kein absehbares
interesse mit der ukrainischen regierung
ernsthaft zu verhandeln du hast es
selbst gesehen die es ist auch
aufgefallen ich habe auch zugehört er
sagte ein treffen zwischen selensky und
putin käme nur dann in frage wenn es gut
vorbereitet sei und wenn es für russland
einen mehrwert biete und der folge satz
war dann gleich wieder die demontage des
ukrainischen der ukrainischen führung
des ukrainischen präsidenten nicht weit
davon entfernt fiel dann wieder der
begriff neonazis also daran zu glauben
dass russland in der ukrainischen
führung in präsident selensky
ernstzunehmende diplomatische partner
auf gleicher augenhöhe sieht glaube ich
das ist im moment noch etwas
abwegig
danke für diese einordnung hier aus
mainz aus der russischen sicht sozusagen
ausblick eines moskau korrespondenten
zur einordnung dessen was wir heute
gehört haben danke axel
ja wie gesagt wir haben die hoffnung
gehabt dass es irgendeinen fortschritt
gibt dass es vielleicht zumindest flucht
korridore gibt dass man über eine
waffenruhe spricht nichts dergleichen
hat sich heute bewahrheitet wir haben
sehr lange den russischen außenminister
gehört er hat auch einfach länger
gesprochen aber während er sprach das
muss man dazu sagen denn so ist das in
diesen zeiten wenn zwei kriegsparteien
verhandeln und hinterher vor die presse
treten das war damit zu rechnen sie
tun's gleichzeitig denn keiner will
sozusagen sich die blöße geben auf den
anderen gewartet zu haben und insofern
wollen wir noch ein bisschen nachholen
was der ukrainische aussenminister die
metro clever gesagt hat und hier noch
einmal eine zusammenfassung aus seiner
perspektive
herr davutoglu hat große anstrengungen
unternommen zwei seiten
zusammenzubringen
ich bin hierhergekommen um flucht
korridore einzurichten aus mario pohl
weil das die stadt ist in der die
humanitäre situation am kritischsten ist
und zweitens haben wir über die 24
stündige waffenruhe diskutiert um ihr
zuzustimmen bin ich hierher gekommen um
die situation der eingeschlossenen
menschen
anzugehen und das problem zu lösen
herr lavrov sagte er würde darüber
beraten und mit entscheidungsträgern in
russland darüber diskutieren
und ich hoffe dass er dabei etwas
ausarbeiten kann in puncto humanitäre
korridore und
ich hoffe dass diese korridore
geschaffen werden basierend auf verstand
und mitgefühl
viele menschen leiden unter den
bombardierungen und unter dem beschuss
auch kinder und babys
wollen wir predator triebe hin zu holen
sie ist von der konrad adenauer stiftung
und ist war die leiterin des
auslandsbüros kharkiv da waren sie
können sie im moment nicht sein aber
bevor wir nachfragen wie sie sozusagen
die situation vor ort ist erstmal ihre
bilanz dessen was ihr heute gehört haben
sind sie enttäuscht
ja ich bin ich enttäuscht weil ich habe
nicht viel erwartet ich habe eigentlich
genau das erwartet und wir mussten es ja
noch einmal hören durch diese sehr lange
erklärung von lampen auf was die
russische position ist es geht ihnen um
die völlige politische und militärische
kontrolle der ukraine sie nennen es den
offizieren die militarisierung
des landes und da hat sich nichts
geändert und ich denke gerade wenn wir
über diesen waffenstillstand reden diese
humanitären flucht korridore die für die
ukraine wirklich sehr sehr wichtig sind
im moment müssen wir auch alleine
dieses russische vorgehen als eine
strategie verstehen denn sie halten sich
ja nicht an vereinbarungen die in den
letzten zwei wochen getroffen worden und
ich denke das ist absicht dass es
strategie um die bevölkerung in der
ukraine gerade in diesem umkämpften
städten weiter zur demoralisierung aber
auch um die ukrainische führung weiter
unter druck zu setzen dann nehmen sie
uns ein bisschen mit in die ukraine wie
sie das erlebt haben und wie man es in
der ukraine sieht einerseits sehen wir
immense bilder von zerstörungen und wir
sehen auch dass menschen in jedweder
form leiden was die verpflegung
anbetrifft was die versorgung anbetrifft
was was fluchtbewegungen anbetrifft
welche hoffnung und erwartung hat man
denn in der ukraine bei allem was die
lens gesagt dass man durchhalten will
dass man kämpfen will aber aus der
bevölkerung das ist sozusagen das was
sie auch hören und worum es jetzt geht
die situation wirklich von stunde zu
stunde schwieriger gerade in der ost
ukraine und in der stadt in der ich auf
zwei jahre gelebt habe aber auch in all
den anderen städten ob sowie oder iso
mario pohl das sind dramatische bilder
und ich kann ihnen sagen das wird in den
nächsten tagen noch schlimmer werden
weil die russische seite ihren
angriffskrieg nicht einstellen wird und
weiter auf diese zivile infrastruktur
ausgerichtet ist aber dennoch vernehme
ich in meinen gesprächen mit den
ukrainern und ukrainerin vor ort und
auch mit den menschen die sich gerade
schon auf der flucht befinden sie wollen
sich weiter wehren sie unterstützen den
widerstand der ukrainischen führung und
sie unterstützen das vorgehen des
ukrainischen militärs so so schwer es
ist für sie aber nach wie vor halten die
menschen daran fest für diese
unabhängige und freie ukraine zu kämpfen
und ich höre auch noch von vielen
menschen dass sie an einen sieg glauben
und ich denke die ukrainische führung
weiß jeder tag indem sie durchhalten ist
vielleicht für sie auch ein
erfolgreicher tag so schlimm dieser
krieg natürlich für das land ist auch
wenn heute keinerlei fortschritt erzielt
wurde aber schauen wir trotzdem nach
vorne wo ein möglicher weg sein könnte
und nehmen eine einen kommentar dazu von
christian krippen stapel der via youtube
schreibt gegen die neutralität der
ukraine wäre doch nichts zu sagen mach
das und beendet den krieg jetzt auch
selensky hat sich gestern geäußert und
ein paar
verhandlungspunkte sozusagen genannt was
was den bombers anbetrifft also den
östlichen teil der ukraine was auch eine
nato-mitgliedschaft betrifft aber
offenkundig hat das nicht gereicht um
heute irgendwelche fortschritte zu
erzielen aber nochmal aus ihrer
perspektive wie sehr kann und will sich
denn die regierung das land ukraine
bewegen um etwas gegen den aggressor
russland entgegenzusetzen
so ich gehe davon aus dass die
ukrainische führung nach wie vor sehr
besonnen reagiert und agiert und dass
sie bereit wären die ihre eigene
bevölkerung zu schützen und dafür
zugeständnisse zu machen die aber für
die ukraine ja in jeglicher hinsicht
grundsätzlich wären weil es würde ja
darum gehen eigenes territorium
abzutreten ein angriffskrieg sozusagen
für russland als erfolg darstellen zu
lassen das ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
lage für die ukrainische führung ich
kann mir aber vorstellen dass es dort
bewegungen gibt und bezüglich der
neutralität das ist so ein argument was
wir häufiger in deutschland hören weil
das klingt erstmal nach einer einfachen
konfliktlösung aber was heißt denn
neutralität der ukraine aus russischer
perspektive
ich denke nicht dass das bedeuten würde
dass die russische seite der ukraine
tatsächlich sicherheit garantieren würde
und tatsächlich die territoriale
unabhängigkeit und integrität der
ukraine ermöglichen würde und so lange
dass die ukraine nicht hat wird sie sich
weiter verteidigen und wir sehen ist ja
in den letzten zwei wochen die ukraine
sind bereit sich mit allen mitteln zu
verteidigen denn das ein ganz wichtiger
punkt neutralität heißt nicht in ruhe
gelassen zu werden oder eben in ruhe und
in frieden leben zu können und deswegen
noch mal den punkt weil sie es fallen
auch sagten jedes zugeständnis
wird in moskau als erfolg für putin
gefeiert werden egal wie hoch der preis
dafür war und die botschaft die
natürlich co notiert die da mitschwingt
wäre krieg lohnt sich in irgendeiner
form gibt es einen ausweg aus dieser
logik
ja allerdings und man muss ja sagen
jetzt im nachhinein diese lehrer hat ja
die russische führung nach 2014 nach der
illegalen aktionen der krim gemacht dass
man ebenso vorgehen kann und damit
erfolg hat und genau diese strategie
probieren sie jetzt und deswegen war es
ja so wichtig und ist es so wichtig dass
der westen so hart und so eindeutig
reagiert hat und
das ist
tatsächlich finde ich als eine sehr sehr
schwierige lage auch für uns eben als
die westlichen verbündeten der ukraine
wir dürfen jetzt keine zugeständnisse
machen die der russischen führung
analysieren man kann etwas damit
gewinnen und ich möchte auch noch einmal
betonen ich glaube nicht dass es der
russischen führung und dem russischen
präsidenten reicht jetzt die ost ukraine
einzunehmen vielleicht die volksrepublik
die sogenannten volksrepublik im donbass
zu erweitern es geht ihm um die
komplette einnahme der des landes und
die politische und militärische
kontrolle das heißt das erste ziel ist
hier ist die hauptstadt ist die
politische führung des landes
und erst das wird der sieg für punkten
sein und sie versuchen das irgendwie an
den letzten tagen ja alles um diese
stadt einzunehmen um diesen widerstand
zu brechen und das ist natürlich für die
ukraine nicht akzeptabel die eigene
hauptstadt und natürlich die eigene
politische führung zu opfern die
übrigens demokratisch gewählt ich will
noch ein paar kommentare zusammenfassen
mal auf die schnelle eine motion
schreibt schutzschild davon hatte lawrow
auf gesprochen solche lügen und man hat
einfach keine man hat einfach eine
geburtsklinik
bombardiert und was er davon
schutzschild phasen zu schreibt sie und
aus teams schreibt via youtube der typ
rechtfertigt gerade einen verschuldeten
krieg was zum teufel ist mit der
menschheit los penny schreibt man kann
den russen nicht trauen die haben sich
jegliches vertrauen längst verspielt und
harald max über youtube ich über falle
ein nachbarland und gebe denen die sich
dagegen wehren die schuld frau triebel
wenn man diese kommentare hört das kann
man verstehen ich habe auch schon axel
starben danach gefragt es hilft aber
alles nichts irgendwie muss man ja auch
mal den perspektivwechsel versuchen um
eine diplomatische lösung zu finden
alles in allem auch wenn es vielleicht
ein bisschen naiv klingt war es trotzdem
richtig sich heute zu treffen um zu
versuchen einen weg zu finden das das
bomben dass das töten nicht einfach
weitergeht
es war richtig dass die außenminister
sich heute getroffen haben es ist
richtig dass auch weitere
regierungschefs der westlichen staaten
versuchen mit putting im gespräch zu
bleiben zu vermitteln es ist auch
richtig dass die ukrainische seite
weiter bilateral mit der russischen
seite in belarus verhandelt denn
natürlich müssen wir alles versuchen
diesen krieg so schnell wie möglich zu
stoppen aber wir müssen auch realistisch
sein und eine schnelle lösung dieses
krieges und ein schneller frieden ist
nicht nichts in aussicht gestellt also
wir können nicht damit rechnen und wir
müssen uns diesen realitäten stellen und
diese realitäten bedeuten jetzt eine
weitere aggressive politik russland in
der ukraine aber auch gegenüber der
gesamten europäischen union und die
daraus resultierenden konsequenzen für
uns in europa weitere flüchtlingsströme
weitere hilfe besucher der ukrainischen
regierung nach waffen nach größeren
sanktionspaket all das wird uns die
nächsten wochen bestätigen und ich gehe
von einem sehr langen krieg und sehr
langen konflikt mit russland aus
brigitta trieben danke für diese
einordnung keine guten worte aber welche
die wir uns heute glaube ich wirklich
vergegenwärtigen müssen für alle die
hoffnung hatten dass der bewegung
reinkommt danke also für diese
informationen dank auch an euch dass ihr
fragen und kommentare abgegeben hat wir
machen es kurz werten gerne bessere
nachrichten gab es auch wir schauen
natürlich auf das was dort passiert auch
wir denken darüber nach was dort
passiert auch mit emotionen gehört dazu
und auch wir sind sozusagen ernüchtert
heute dass wir sagen müssen so ist der
stand und bw kabel von frau triebe
gehört haben dieser krieg wird uns noch
lange und länger beschäftigen damit
müssen wir uns glaube ich heute
auseinandersetzen danke für eure
aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten mal